Prince Harry is on paternity leave but
he is taking a break this morning he's
in the Netherlands promoting the
Invictus games for wounded warriors
while his wife stays home with their
newborn son
you heard it his name is Archie mts tyub
is in Windsor England where the Royals
revealed the baby's name yesterday empty
as it was an unexpected surprise
it really was a major surprise then well
even though dad Prince Harry is already
back at first and we do know that mum
Megan is resting at Frogmore cottage
which is not far from here with her
newborn son her mum is there to Doria
Raglan who's here all the way from
California but that name wow that baby
name has made a splash not only here in
Britain but right around the world it's
the Royal Instagram post that got a
million likes in less than an hour
announcing a royal baby name unlike most
others Archie Harrison
mountbatten-windsor Alan Jones is a
royal correspondent for the Press
Association who asked Prince Harry to
show the world more of his newborn son's
face he says it's a modern name fitting
for a modern royal Harry knows he's not
in direct line to the throne knew there
was a son B so he probably thought well
we can we can call him a quite easygoing
name so Archie is lovely he's relaxed
Megan and Harry haven't said why they
chose the name although Archie is one of
the 20 most popular four boys in Britain
and Harrison literally means son of
Harry I think it works yeah why so how's
that well that's part of their history
and Archie Archie yeah I'm not sure
where that came from
mountbatten-windsor is already used by
some members of the royal family and was
created to recognize the lineage of
Queen Elizabeth a Windsor and Prince
Philip Mountbatten who wasn't able to
pass on his name to his own children
says Ingrid Seward who's writing the
book about him Prince Philip would be so
pleased the Queen issued a decree that
henceforth royal children if they didn't
have their
titles would be called
mountbatten-windsor which could in part
explain why Harry and Megan decided to
decline a courtesy title for their
newborn son young Archie could have had
a title of one of his father's
subsidiary titles such as the Duke of
Dumbarton he also could have been known
as Lord Archie but his parents decided
no we're not going to do that and he
will be known as Master Archie Harrison
mountbatten-windsor Gale I like it MT as
ty have I heard that they just want to
keep it casual but Archie means genuine
bold and brave not so bad in Harrison
son of Harry also very nice